now  all right thank you so much for being  here at noon and we start with this  video here some activity at harry reid  international crews are working to  remove a small cessna plane it  overturned on the runway as you can see  the call came in around 9 30 this  morning two people were told were on  board but they did not need medical  assistance  as of now the airport says the incident  isn't causing any delays or  cancellations so so good news all around  but boy it is sure windy out that out  there nate and as i send it over to you  obviously that could have contributed to  the problem yeah we cannot say legally  or definitively that that was the reason  for that plane flipping over but i think  it's logical to presume that that's  going to be the focus of the  investigation